i have a we're going to look at a couple
of videos from attendees at the
youngstown ohio trump rally over the
weekend this was the rally at which
donald trump was supposedly going to
support jd vance although he at one
point made fun of jd vance but that
doesn't really matter let's look at some
of the videos of people who went this
one is unbelievable
uh there is a
woman
who is thrilled that trump called out to
her even though trump referred to her as
this guy
this
especially with everything that's going
on right now
with trump's transphobia and the
resurgence of transphobia among the
rights something about this video just
cracks me up check this out
what about time it was wonderful
president talk to me
beforehand or at the end at the end i
hollered i loved him he stopped and he
said i love you too and then he thought
he said this guy says he loves me and i
said well i'm a woman
oh it's it it all of these events are
completely beyond parody i mean it's
it's unbelievable it's unbelievable and
it's funny because these folks love to
say
democrats and the left you don't know
what a woman is you can't identify a
woman it's so obvious what's a woman
what's a man who's a woman who's a man
and then now it's all a big joke that
trump thought
this woman was a man
i guess some republicans struggle with
that as well it seems and it sort of
puts into particular perspective these
absurd transphobic anecdotes that donald
trump now regularly tells it as rallies
another interview that took place with a
rally attendee was actually with a
january sixth defendant mickey larson
known as the cue patriot i guess
was interviewed by donald trump's
attorney christina bob who is also an
anchor on right side broadcasting i mean
every detail is absurd take a listen to
i served air this
for 21 years i'm a january 6 defendant
can we say that
and i wrote a phone call we're ready to
fight i have a copy i'll give to you oh
that sounds great you look fantastic
what prompted the outfit
i started this after the election was
stolen
i actually by the way so the the woman
is dressed with
i can't even describe it she seems to
have like a tentacle wig of red white
and blue
and then like a crazy glitter hat and
it's just it's an insane outfit and it's
funny because it's like what what made
you start dressing like this well when
they stole the election from trump i
started dressing like a lunatic oh that
makes sense a halloween costume and i
was in arizona doing a patriot party out
there
and my costume was in abilene texas
so i was like i need to find a reason to
wear it so the first time i wore it was
november of 2021
at a maggot car rally and then it just
became a thing and now i wear it to all
the events well it is great you look
fantastic it's energizing i think people
are excited i'm going to bring it over
here to brian who's got announcement
yeah they're going to try to get it
looked like christina bob actually got a
signal from someone off camera to get
away from that and then this is the last
this is really really funny
you know how it's a very it's like a
point of pride at some of these rallies
to say you came from really far away it
really just proves your cultist
credentials but they love to say oh i
drove five hours 10 hours whatever a
woman explains she drove five hours to
the trump rally and the interviewer
tries to push on her that the gas prices
were probably crazy and the woman admits
you know their gas prices really weren't
that
bad how long does that drive
five hours and 20 minutes too bad but
i'm sure the gas prices were bad well uh
you know what's too bad
for what a year and a half there's
they've been saying joe biden's gas
prices are destroying the country and
this woman goes you know we came from
five hours away really we didn't really
pay that much gas prices were actually
quite reasonable
every little detail of this cult
is
putting snl out of business i mean you
can't really parody this and then the
last component of this the last
component of this yes
is mike pillow let's go to that next
the david pakman show's longest running
sponsor is blinkist the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
each of them down into an explainer you
can read or listen to in 15 minutes
blinkist also condenses episodes of
popular podcasts into 15 minute
explainers i've been using blinkist for
years to supplement the books i read i
love reading i i read all the time but
there's even more books i don't have
time to read and you can often find
those non-fiction books on blinkist and
consume the entire thing in 15 minutes
my favorite new feature on the app is
blinkist connect which lets you share
your blinkist premium account with
someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users i have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to robert greene's the 48 laws of power
the new version robert greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 percent off a
premium subscription at blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below